vamos a aplicar lo que hicimos en el
vídeo pasado haciendo un ejemplo
concreto del trabajo que hace un campo
vectorial sobre una partícula que se
mueve por este campo siguiendo una
cierta trayectoria
entonces supongamos que tenemos un campo
vectorial efe lo voy a poner un poco más
bonito efe que está definido en el plano
xy entonces es una función de xy que
asocia un vector a cada punto del plano
supongamos que este campo vectorial está
dado por ye por y el vector unitario y
menos x por el vector unitario j
saleh vamos a hacer un dibujo para ver
cómo se ve esto en el plano déjame
dibujar el plano y por acá ese de ahí es
el eje y acá perpendicularmente tenemos
el eje x y entonces el campo vectorial
asocia un vector a cada uno de los
puntos
en el plano xy vamos a pensar a estos
como vectores de fuerza aquí va x aquí
vale entonces por ejemplo para el punto
10 como se vería el vector que le asocia
el campo vectorial pues en 10 y es igual
a cero entonces sería cero por y menos
uno por jota menos jsb así se ve como un
vector hacia abajo de magnitud 1
deja como aquí la flechita en x igual a
es decir el punto 20 que todavía sería 0
pero ahora la fuerza sería menos dos
veces jota entonces tendríamos una
flecha de este estilo menos dos j va de
modo similar si nos vamos a este punto
en donde es igual a 1 y x es igual a 0
entonces tenemos ya iguala 11 por y
menos 0 por j entonces el vector es de
magnitud 1 a la derecha y comienza en el
0.1 creo que más o menos le estás
agarrando la onda de cómo se ve pero por
ejemplo vamos a poner unos cuantos más
si tenemos un punto aquí entonces el
vector va a subir hacia allá luego si
tenemos un punto digamos por aquí
entonces ahora va a quedar inclinado
hacia abajo hacia la derecha y creo que
en general se ve como que va girando de
quererlo podría llenar todo el plano con
vectores deja nada más lo dejo un poco
más simétrico si estuviera en este punto
de por acá entonces el vector subiría
así en fin efe nos garantiza un vector
en cada punto del plano
vamos a poner una partícula a moverse en
este campo vectorial supongamos que su
trayectoria está sobre la curva ce y que
la parametrización de ce está dada por x
de t es igual a coseno de t
es igual a seno de t y ahora tenemos que
decir el intervalo supongamos que pues
que 0 es menor o igual que t y es menor
o igual que 2 y va entonces a lo mejor
ya reconociste cómo se va a ver esta
curva esta parametrización nos da un
círculo recorrido en sentido antihorario
entonces la trayectoria empieza aquí
para cuando te es igual a cero te
podemos pensarlo como un tiempo o como
un ángulo pero aquí vamos a pensarlo
como un tiempo va entonces al tiempo
cero la trayectoria empieza aquí cuando
el tiempo se va moviendo digamos a pi
medios entonces empezamos a recorrer el
círculo hasta su cuarta parte recuerda
que estamos yendo en esta dirección o
sea en sentido antihorario luego a los
segundos vamos a haber llegado hasta acá
y finalmente cuando avancemos hasta dos
pi vamos a haberle dado una vuelta
completa al círculo dicho de otra forma
lo que está haciendo nuestra trayectoria
es girar alrededor del origen una vez y
recorriendo se en sentido antihorario ya
tenemos dibujada la curva pero ahora sí
cuál es el trabajo hecho por este campo
vectorial sobre esta curva
entonces el trabajo
ya vimos en el vídeo pasado que es igual
a la integral la integral de línea sobre
c esta curva se de nuestro campo
vectorial o sea de f
punto producto puntocom pues con el
diferencial de nuestro movimiento es
decir punto de r todavía ni siquiera
hemos dicho quién es ese rey nada más
tenemos una parametrización estándar lo
que hay que hacer es pasar esta
parametrización a forma vectorial de
modo que nos describa esta trayectoria
esta es una parametrización estándar y
para escribirla en forma vectorial le
voy a poner que r ya con su vector de t
es igual a equis dt o sea coseno de t x
el vector y más
7 o sea seno de x el vector jota y de
modo similar esto es para 0 menor o
igual que t menor o igual que 2 pi
saleh estas dos parametrización es
recorren la misma trayectoria solo que
me tomé la molestia de pasar la forma
vectorial porque así ya puedo encontrar
el vector derivada de r y hacerle el
producto punto con efe vamos a calcular
todo eso para encontrar el trabajo hecho
por el campo vectorial sobre la
partícula pero antes de eso a lo mejor
ya triste cuenta de algo estamos yendo
en sentido antihorario pero por cada
punto por el que pasamos el campo
vectorial parece ser que va en dirección
contraria como nos movemos por ejemplo
aquí vamos hacia arriba pero el campo va
hacia abajo acá vamos hacia arriba a la
izquierda pero el campo hacia abajo a la
derecha
en este punto vamos a la izquierda y el
campo va hacia la derecha entonces
parece que el campo siempre va en
dirección contraria a la nuestra
la intuición física que está detrás es
que esto va a tener que ver con trabajo
negativo
por ejemplo cuando levanto un objeto del
piso yo estoy aplicando una fuerza
positiva hacia arriba pero la gravedad
está aplicando una fuerza negativa ok
ahora sí pasemos a las cuentas
para encontrar el trabajo digo esta
explicación está padre verdad nos ayuda
a entender más o menos qué está pasando
en el fondo voy a poner una fecha más en
este punto mejor con rosa qué es lo que
hemos estado usando ahí está en este
punto también vamos a la izquierda
siempre nos movemos en dirección
contraria a la del campo vectorial vale
ahora sí pasemos a las cuentitas un buen
lugar para empezar es la derivada de
nuestro vector de posición es decir la
derivada con respecto a t déjame ponerlo
aquí de r entre de t
esto también se puede escribir como r
prima de t y es igual a pues aquí
tenemos que derivar con respecto a tec
la derivada de coche no es menos seno de
t x y más la derivada de seno de t con
respecto a t es la derivada de seno que
es coseno de t x j ahora para obtener el
diferencial multiplicamos todo por de t
nos queda de r
de r es igual a y lo que tenemos que
hacer es escribir esta expresión de aquí
arriba entonces nos queda menos seno de
t por de t simplemente estoy
multiplicando por t y distribuyéndolo x
y más coseno de t por de t por jota
entonces ya tenemos esta parte de la
integral pero ahora hay que hacer el
producto punto con efe déjame reescribir
el campo vectorial para que todo quede
en términos de t vamos a necesitar esto
para poder evaluar la integral queremos
saber la fuerza en cada punto de la
trayectoria pero ojo hay algunos puntos
del plano xy que no nos importan por
ejemplo aquí el campo vectorial tiene
esta dirección pero ese punto no está en
nuestra trayectoria y por tanto esa
fuerza no tiene impacto en la partícula
por esta razón lo que necesitamos es una
función que sustituya a equis y aie por
sus valores correspondientes en términos
de t con esto vamos a poder obtener la
fuerza aplicada en cada tiempo t y esto
es justamente lo que necesitamos para
poder calcular la integral de línea
entonces nos queda que
efe dt o sea como función de t es igual
a g pero tiene que ser 7 entonces
tenemos que ponerle seno de esa parte x
y x y más bueno en realidad es menos x
pero es x dt es decir coseno de t
jose no de t x el vector j y ahora si
con estos dos elementos ya podemos
encontrar la integral de línea si
queremos encontrar esta integral de
línea simplemente debemos hacer un
producto punto lo voy a poner aquí abajo
nos va a quedar lo voy a poner con otro
color entonces va a ser la integral
desde t igual a cero hasta t igualados
df punto de r aquí está f y aquí está de
r entonces cuando queremos hacer el
producto puntos simplemente
multiplicamos coordenada coordenada y
luego sumamos entonces el producto punto
de aquí nos queda vamos a ver es seno de
t por seno de t y luego con signo
negativo entonces nos queda menos seno
cuadrado de t
dt y luego vamos al otro lado queremos
sumarle déjame reescribir el dt que
quedó muy feo lo voy a poner de té y
ahora a esto queremos sumarle la
multiplicación de estos dos entonces lo
escribo nos queda menos a mejores temas
lo cambio por menos
sería menos coseno cuadrado de t por de
t
sale ahora si factor izamos el signo
menos entonces nos va a quedar igual a
la integral desde cero hasta dos pi de
haber nos queda seno cuadrado de a no
perdón pero es seno cuadrado de t más
coseno cuadrado de t y sabes que para
arreglar esto del menos mejor vamos a
sacarlo de la integral entonces voy a
poner un menos aquí esto se vuelven más
y entonces aquí aparece un menos vale y
luego hay que multiplicar por bt bueno
ahí hay algunos pasitos algebraicos no
hacen nada raro verdad simplemente
factorización menos lo distribuir y puse
el dt también factor izado va entonces
ahora si queremos resolver esta integral
que obtuvimos aquí pero es súper súper
sencilla verdad seno cuadrado más coseno
cuadrado de cualquier cosa siempre es 1
eso viene de las identidades
trigonométricas entonces esta expresión
vale 1 y entonces la integral se
simplifica lo siguiente a menos la
integral de 0 a 2 pi
dt
esta es una integral facilísima podemos
pensar que aquí hay un 1 para que no
quede tan sólido el dt y ya con esto
estamos por terminar tenemos que la
integral es igual a menos simplemente es
el signo menos que ya traíamos desde
arriba menos la anti derivada de uno que
éste y eso de ahí hay que evaluarlo en
dos pi en cero y restar entonces eso de
ahí es igual a menos s menos de ahí dos
pi
y luego menos de hoja -0 eso de ahí
simplemente es igual a menos 2 pi listo
ya terminamos encontramos el trabajo
hecho por el campo vectorial sobre la
partícula que se está moviendo sobre la
trayectoria ce en dirección antihorario
observa como el resultado coincide con
nuestra intuición obtuvimos un número
negativo esto fue porque en cada punto
del campo vectorial va en dirección
contraria al movimiento de la partícula
sobre la trayectoria bueno espero que
con este vídeo ya quede un poco más
claro de qué se trata la integral de
línea sobre un campo vectorial